(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Democrats
led by President Biden say
now is the time to build back better.
- The American Jobs Plan
will modernize 20,000 miles
on highways, roads, and main
street that are in difficult,
difficult shape right now.
- [Narrator] But leaders don't
just want to build and update
roads, in some cases they
want highways torn down.
Democrats would like to
provide funding to tear
down highways that had a damaging effect
on urban minority communities.
- Federal funds created
the damage done here and
federal funds should be used
to help remedy it.
- [Narrator] Activists in cities
like Tampa, Austin, Texas,
New Orleans, Detroit, and
Tulsa, Oklahoma are calling
for the removal of highways
that they say segregate
communities and harm minorities.
Leaders say there are many
more examples like this road
in West Baltimore.
This is the Franklin-Mulberry Expressway,
Baltimore locals call it
the highway to nowhere
and some policymakers
want to tear it down.
The road cuts through
1.4 miles of the city
providing a speedy route for
cars traveling east to west.
Like other parts of the
country's Interstate System,
the road was built to provide
fast access for traffic
from ports and downtown
offices to the suburbs,
but locals like Baltimore
City Councilman John Bullock
say it's a scar running
through the city's west side.
- The reality is that you
did have intact, businesses,
churches, families, community
networks that were literally
torn asunder with this
highway going through.
And yes, there are examples
of cities across the country
and Baltimore is no different
that during urban renewal
you saw the disproportionate
effects in neighborhoods
that had African-American populations.
- [Narrator] Planning for this
road dates back to the 1950s
when President Eisenhower
called for cities to build
better connections to
the Interstate System.
His goal was to give the
military, traders, and commuters
quick routes through the nation.
In Baltimore the first round
of demolition displaced
hundreds of families,
that sparked a wave of
opposition from locals
like then City Councilwoman
Barbara Mikulski who would go on
to represent Maryland in
Congress as a Democrat.
- [Barbara] New government
under eminent domain tucked
their house and cleared that
land without any relocation
benefits but they have a
fair market value in showing.
- [Narrator] Senator Chris
Van Hollen is Mikulski's
successor.
- What you see here is a part
of the highway that was built
decades ago but was never
completed because Senator Mikulski
and other activists rallied to stop it,
and they were successful
at stopping the highway
but not before this one
and a half mile segment
had been built displacing over
900 people from their homes,
splitting an African American
community that had been stable
and vibrant and so here you see this scar.
- [Narrator] Since then researchers
have found that highways
create challenging
conditions within cities.
Data collected in Baltimore
suggests that air quality
is poorest and the sections
of the city that are near
Interstate connections.
The Environmental Protection
Agency says that poor air
quality can worsen health
conditions like asthma.
The Interstate also
contributed to out migration,
not only in Baltimore but
in cities across the country
like Detroit.
Economists say that the highway
building in majority Black
Detroit contributed to the
city's economic decline.
Maintenance costs for these
roads continue to weigh
on the city which filed
for bankruptcy in 2013.
This form of structural
inequity is what leaders
in Washington say they
are trying to address.
- Too often investments have
failed to meet the needs
of marginalized communities left behind.
- [Narrator] Developers today
say that tearing down parts
of the Interstate System
could correct a wave
of past failures.
One 2018 review of West Baltimore
calls for the demolition
of two bridges at the
Eastern stub of the highway
opening more land for development.
The plan says the new space could be used
for athletic fields, parks,
and a new retail center.
The panel also called for the
rehabilitation of vacant lots
in nearby row homes and wider
sidewalks for pedestrians.
If Congress passes an infrastructure bill
the federal funding could help turn some
of these ideas into reality.
West Baltimore Community
Organizer, Ashiah Parker
says she would welcome changes
in her part of the city
but she wants to make sure
the community has a seat
at the table.
- We definitely don't want
our federal partners putting
up large condos that people aren't able,
well that current residents
aren't able to occupy.
And then we also wanna make
sure that economic development
is done.
So produce stores are other
types of small businesses
for people who are
already in a neighborhood
that can utilize.
- [Narrator] Other residents
said that they would like
for the government to focus
on rehabilitating homes
in the area before focusing on the roads.
The national movement to tear
down highways is picking up
steam as leaders in Congress
from both sides of the aisle
signal that they're open to the idea.
The movement got a boost
from President Biden
when he called for $20 billion
to redress inequities created
by past investments in transportation.
That's just one part of the
bigger American Jobs Plan
which the White House says
would cost $1.7 trillion.
Senate Republicans now
say that they are open
to a nearly $1 trillion
infrastructure plan.
In short, both parties want to invest more
in infrastructure but they're
far apart on the details
of how it should be done.
Republican senators say they're
open to using federal funds
to remove highways but they
want to leave the decision
to state lawmakers.
- There are multiple examples
of poor planning decisions
that have led to adverse
consequences for specific
communities.
None of us denying that
and I think we all agree
they should be rectified.
I believe it should be done at the local
and state level where
decision-makers are closest
to the people and able to
make a balanced decision.
- [Narrator] The call to
fund highway removal breaks
from years of American
transportation philosophy.
If a bill materializes highway
tear downs could unfold
in cities across the country.
(upbeat music)